and now we are on to just sort of the
last topic which has to do with the
resampling approach and resampling
approaches are are really really
powerful tool
um
that gives us a way to conduct
hypothesis testing either a single
hypothesis test or a lot of hypothesis
tests
um in a way that's relatively assumption
free
so what is this all about well in this
lecture so far we've assumed that we're
in the scenario where we want to test
some null hypothesis H naught we have a
test statistic T and most importantly we
know or else we feel like we can assume
the distribution of t under the null
hypothesis
and that's how we were able to compute
the p-value was by knowing the
distribution of the test statistic under
the null hypothesis so remember this
figure from before and the distribution
of t under the null hypothesis was this
yellow curve in this in this particular
example the distribution of t under the
null was a um approximately a normal
distribution but in general depending on
your null hypothesis depending on your T
statistic that null distribution of the
test statistic could be a different
distribution an unknown or it could be
unknown right and in fact that's the
idea here is what if this theoretical
null distribution is actually unknown
we just don't know what it looks like or
alternatively we could make some
assumptions under which we might know
what it looks like but maybe we we feel
a little bit weird making those
assumptions because we don't really
think they're going to hold
oh reward they might not hold at least
we're worried they might not hold we
just want to do something that's a
little bit more assumption free
so one way we can do this is using a
resampling type of approach and the
thing we should say about resampling
approaches before we get into the
details is that it's a very general
framework that needs to be instantiated
in a specific way depending on the type
of hypothesis you're testing and the
type of test it is you're using So today
we're going to talk about what a
resampling approach will look like for
conducting a two-sample t-test but in
general if you're testing a different
type of null hypothesis it's not just a
difference in means or if you have a
test statistic that's not just a
two-sample T Test you're going to need
to figure out whether there is an
appropriate resampling approach for you
and also what that resampling approach
looks like so this is going to really
require some hard thinking and it's not
Plug and Play the way that a lot of
things that we've seen so far in this
lecture are so the idea is suppose that
we want to test the null hypothesis that
uh the mean in in one group equals the
mean in another group versus the
alternative that they're unequal and
here we have N Sub X independent
observations from X and N Sub y
independent observations from y well
then as we've already seen today the two
sample T statistic takes the form of
just the sample mean in group x minus
sample mean in group y divided by an
estimate of the standard deviation
between mu X of mu x minus mu y
and if n x and n y are large then as
we've already said t approximately
follows a normal 0 1 distribution under
the null hypothesis
but what happens if n x and n y are
small well in that case we actually
don't know the theoretical nil
distribution of T unless we make further
assumptions about the distribution of
the the data the distribution of the x's
and the Y's
so what we can do is we can try to take
a resampling approach and the idea
behind a resampling approach is that
instead of just like looking up in a
textbook with the theoretical null
distribution of T is or taking our word
for it or deriving it yourself if that's
your thing we're actually just going to
let a computer sort of simulate for us
what the null distribution of T would
look like under the null hypothesis